au c'ur du postdam tous attention
basraoui enfin peut-être machine n'est
pas faire du buzz n'était pas faire l
affaire coq et chers abonnés chers
abonnés je le mot d'ordre à la maison
c'est amusant nous ayons beaucoup de
passion envers les billets qui n'ont pas
volé je me suis dit que contrairement
aux autres qui pensent qu'à l'argent
moi je ne voulais pas pensé oublier
qu'ils ne volent pas par passion que je
m'amusais mais ça va et que voilà le
plaisir est vraiment le mot d'ordre
quand quelqu'un ne voit pas les pieds
derrière moi ton fric c'est chic au
jumbo qui s'accouplent actuellement on
tourne à sanaa que mika qui transforme
en un éclair puisque je fais moustache
il est là il y pense rires il rit déjà
d'ailleurs
d'abord vu ils forment une porte on
rigole go auxquels est venu et on est
dans la chambre de michael mais je suis
juste rentré dans la chambre j'ai juste
fait de s'en aller ça fait mal ça fait
mal
des poursuites de making of de l'extrême
on tourne la scène avec mika moustache
et jumbo arrivée fait ses pattes sur le
plateau voilà du doigt les câlins on n'a
pas marqué un but qui vaut une moustache
toi aussi
on peut l'entendre on renaît et les
coulisses de la boîte de nuit une belle
langue d'accrocher un fer à repasser
avec le mode disco disco mode oscar du
meilleur acteur
ok tu n'as pas non